so that said no no I talked to deaf
progress don't touch that I want you yes
I talked it down from the high eighties
I make a progress no I haven't I should
be yeah yeah I appreciate it though it's
always nice to hear griffeys drunk -
guys I think Santa's house is on fire
okay blast your castles entire body just
because you want to show me up I got it
I'm getting emotional here you ever
heard of Omaha Steaks well I couldn't
get him but I got you a gift certificate
keep improving while the cameras on your
back you don't think I can operate this
electric hacksaw do you it's a chainsaw
but anyway well guess who got his
woodlands Management badge in we blows
yes you yes brat me Witek right before I
got kicked out of Indian guides so rad
ends up with a chainsaw okay watch out
for forest rangers and he's gonna cut
down you picks a tree and he's gonna cut
down this tree looks like a nice Douglas
fir right here watch out for Rangers
Brad again was trying to show off that
he was a weeble oh he cut it down
perfectly but didn't realize that it was
a cell phone tower
you got a pinpoint a top 60 degree angle
Top Cat it's kinda like bar you know he
cuts so far into it and all of a sudden
hits the electricity part and he just
poke
[Music]
the big flyback was me
and then you have we'll you know landing
on the ground and and he actually pulled
him right into the scene dragged him
through the snow and Will Ferrel
actually does most of his own stunts and
he really will do I'd say probably 80%
of his own stunts yeah he's a stud
[Laughter]
you